[Music]
in ghost baby news oh [ __ ] submitted by
David as a whole smack thank you
what is he admit you're a boy they did
for three C's how do you know so that's
the way they write at these days I'm hip
to the cool a mother who suffered a
miscarriage is now convinced she's being
haunted by the baby's ghost what it was
she a bad mama like I don't know it's
like why didn't you eat better yeah but
like how are you gonna be haunted by a
fetus though what are they gonna say
nothing it's like this biggest like it
was so hard for me to tell you boy so is
just floating around I'm like what the
Icicle is floating around it's like
they're like you can't even give you the
famous shrimp it's like a furless Mouse
that's living in a sky which sounds
horrifying I wouldn't be that scared of
that I just be kind of freaked out like
what what the [ __ ] it just all this is
float oh that's not David that's all you
got but is that cute though it's not I
didn't think it was cute unless it's
like it like this big it's not that
scary I don't know I need a scissor like
that good look at regional weather has a
floating fetus that doesn't say anything
at all or a five year old girl in a
little white dress give me a fetus give
me a beat exactly no I've seen that so
much but I haven't seen a haunted fetus
here it sounds terrifying what about one
of your eggs died on your maxi pad right
and then the [ __ ] tampon comes a
[ __ ] haunts you
yeah the haunted period is is [ __ ]
surfing on the [ __ ] tampon [ __ ]
Street with a cotton ball that's bloody
that's floating in the sky the hunting
parties if it's trying to like smash
itself - my clothes are like my butt
area where I'm like don't get blood on
me bro words out one rose
oh my god
where do you get ghost bleach I'm ghost
Amazon yeah so what kind of paranormal
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're going through
right now
right so this woman's name is Melissa
she's from Toronto Johnson City she says
that she's always been a paranormal
skeptic of course but that all changed
back in September of 2016 when she
suffered a miscarriage and that's that
same day that she was struck child I
know it's really sad a same day that she
lost her child she claims that the
children's toy randomly turned on itself
right in the middle of the night in the
living room and began playing music Oh
an egg rolls towards you re-read it
bumps into your door dish like if I was
homeless I would love to be invited like
like have a ghost come pay me what come
you know right so so you know there's
there's always like homeless people
walking around they were there talking
to themselves and stuff and I always
have your goes with them exactly I think
they see they're on a different
dimensions that we're not on and we
think they're stupid but I think we're
just not seeing some [ __ ] because how
can you have a full-on conversation for
hours with air it's like a one-sided
conversation though is there a
difference between an invisible friend
and a couple all I know if your theory
is true that means ghosts are either
really mean or they're really funny
because they just need a laugh or
they're cursing no they do they do
ramble also like I think gosh a majority
of the time he's right they are laughing
or yelling that sounds like what Tycho
says right now
he's like messing with the fingers tune
up that's why homeless people and babies
are in the same dimension yeah man and
that's weird and you know how like
babies [ __ ] pick up the phone the
play phone and then bicker talk they
talk in their play phone and they
pretend for hours and see homeless
people picking up the payphone and
they're talking to they're communicating
you know what if Dave Chappelle passed
away right now I would want his ghost to
haunt me so he could write my stand-up
for me oh do they go to work
it's not working he's just gonna be
funny he goes hey dog I just want you to
make my legacy live on through your
jokes and he just sits there it's not
gonna sit right behind me the whole time
I dream of that all the time when famous
people die I'm like please possess me
I'm like a ghost that's just gonna hike
me up all the time you know cuz y'all
ever had that friend it just thinks
you're so funny and they always laugh at
your jokes I went like a ghost that does
it just makes me feel good about myself
you know I like ghosts if they were like
that Melissa says that she caught what
she believes is the faith of her ghost
foetus staring at her at her 8 month old
on the baby cam she has another baby now
an 8 month old oh so this is our older
sibling yeah pretty much
so she's saying that it looks like your
daughter is like trying to get away from
me so maybe they're playing oh that's so
funny tanker does that well explain what
it is on the face in the corner but it
looks like a doll face she says that
they don't have any doll at all in the
home it's the only stuffed animals was
it baby crying oh I see it now it looks
like a little girl baby mm-hmm
yeah that's scary you know Tiger does
that right now
well he doesn't do it as much as the war
what's going on what's the caterpillar
moves for so when babies first start
learning when they have a big milestone
which is like starting a walk or
starting a crawl their brain is still
actively working in that so then even
when they're sleeping they're still
doing it in their sleep or if they learn
how to sit up and they'll sit up but
they're knocked out oh that creepy cuz
if I saw a baby like no no go back go
back knock out but then you starts
crawling and he like that you look like
a caterpillar
I'm like cuz we're integrating the motor
patterns even when they're sleeping so
that's why I do karate in the [ __ ]
sleeps
and her baby lor
so she says also that's a check this
that face on the baby camp she
immediately ran upstairs and grab the
baby in that audio track I wonder if
she's edited with the extra creepy [ __ ]
extra creeper fly that [ __ ]
what if they play like the Benny Hill
soundtrack to that [ __ ] that's so
confusing I know but I'm like how do I
feel about this I'm like oh that's scary
but I I can't think yes that's how did
you present scary [ __ ] like if if it's
really scary then that music will not
unscary you yeah you're really test but
then when you hit that goal shapes
they're gonna happen it's confusing oh
really you condition it yeah yeah that's
that's really far-fetched when they were
her and her husband in the living room
that she heard something fall really
loudly in the kitchen sink and it turned
out to be the lid of their son's sippy
cup that her husband had previously
placed about a foot away from the sink
and so she's saying that it made such a
loud noise that it sounds like it had
been thrown and so now at this point it
was probably just a puddle of water on
the counter you ever go to like dim sum
and then he got to see a surfing cup
yeah it's because there's a puddle of
penis yeah yeah Tiny's dim sum ghost why
duty why are ghosts like Chinese waiters
like [ __ ] clumsy why is it always the
same [ __ ] like ghosts are always like
they're like attention [ __ ] you know
like they want they want to break a
plate they want to like tantrum they
want to throw some water turn off
[ __ ] boss it on it's like do some
different yeah they're all [ __ ] waste
my bathroom floor head or some [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] somewhat the pillow is do
you think I think I would never be
scared of ghosts then at that point like
I think that's the point then they want
a scary well from what spiritual people
say that they want to scare you so then
your sparing your you're gonna Bish's
whatever it's like long low and down
I'll give them scary feelings we just
have to have a negotiation I'll give up
it's like I if they do my laundry right
I'll be scared cuz I'm like get my
laundry you know but what happened you
know my inhibitions is so below because
I feel inadequate I didn't do that he
does gonna be so [ __ ] funny when a
ghost possesses me and he finds out
everything wrong with me
cuz I got in you dumb [ __ ] I have two
broken ankles in a torn knees now he's
in more than obviously the chillin I'm
looking at you stupid [ __ ] I'm falling
out of here you're like a ghost and you
possess someone and they're on a diet
and [ __ ] I can't even [ __ ] eat the
[ __ ] that I want to know they're gonna
follow your diet I think it's unlikely
though that a hundred percent of ghosts
want to scare you there are a few that
are nice out there they're doing nice
stuff and what if we just don't notice I
never want a Skinner Wormley judgy and
ghosts like all the temples and I go to
[ __ ] churches and [ __ ] I'm like
please that their beard goes possessed
the [ __ ] out of me is gonna be the best
drugs Oh what about me though what I
mean we're gonna have a great ass time
we might be there it might be a positive
goal imagine I fall in love with the
ghost what if it's a romantic go yeah
yeah yeah yeah if they're any romantic
ghosts out there uh here you go I
present Exhibit A or it comes into
talking about squeaky clean things on
videos no I think I mean I'm squeaky
clean like a child could not be joke he
doesn't find funny at all
oh my god is it getting warm in here
[Music]